welcome back my friends today's video is
about chivalry of a failed knight so
without further ado let's start just
upon returning to his apartment from
jogging an academy student iki
inadvertently walks in on a half-naked
girl changing in his room while being
admonished and forced to apologize by
the academy director iki learns that the
girl is stella a famous a-rank blazer
who's the princess of the vermillion
empire and his new roommate when stella
announces a set of house rules which ike
objects to the director has them stage a
battle with the loser having to obey the
winner unconditionally iki accepts
despite the disadvantages of his low
rank he's an frank blazer stating that
he has to work hard in order to win the
seven star sword art festival so during
the mock battle he demonstrates powerful
fighting skills and memorizes stella's
techniques which he uses against her
through his technique blade steel as a
last resort stella activates her noble
art but ikky counters it with his own
noble art outmaneuvers her attacks and
strikes her winning the battle but
collapsing from exhaustion later the
director visits stella and explains that
despite ikky's strength he flunked the
academy's evaluations due to his
peculiar style she then recommends her
to follow iki's style so she could
improve returning to the apartment
stella apologizes to him for her
behaviour iki then reminds her of the
deal they made for the loser to obey the
winner from now on and then orders her
to be his roommate iki's younger sister
shizuku who he hasn't seen in four years
arrives at the same academy as a new
student in class iki and stella learned
about the selection match for the seven
star sword art festival from their
teacher afterwards they meet iki's
sister who surprises everyone by kissing
him directly on the mouth leading to a
duel between stella and shizuku over the
former's relationship with iki the
following evening shizuku meets her
roommate meanwhile iki tells stella that
he was born without any talent in a
family that produced great blazers as a
result he was neglected by his family
and later ran away and got lost in a
blizzard but was rescued by his great
grandfather who encouraged him to
believe in himself afterwards he strove
to become just like his
great-grandfather was accepted into the
academy but when his family discovered
it into creating a set of class
requirements which were responsible for
ikky's failing grades until the new
academy director arrived though she's
also pressured as a result iki then
states that his constant harassment will
never come to an end later while he is
taking a bath stella joins him and the
rest i'm sure you can imagine after
training with iki sena tries asking him
out on a date but their conversation
gets interrupted by a text message sent
by shizuku asking him to go shopping
with her stella is shocked when iki
accepts the proposal and decides to
accompany him during the shopping trip
rmc has an awkward first meeting with
shizuku's roommate alice the entire trip
is spent with stella and iki's sister
competing to get his attention with
shizuku seemingly triumphing every time
as the four split up to use the
restrooms the mall is suddenly taken
hostage by a group of armed men led by a
blazer he demands a large ransom in
exchange for the release of the hostages
the academy director authorizes iki and
the others to use their devices to
attack the assailants when stella
intervenes to save a little boy the
blazer subdues her with his device
judgment ring and then forces her to
undress and apologize otherwise they'll
kill the hostages shizuku takes
advantage of the gunmen's distraction to
protect herself stella and the hostages
with a wall of water while iki jumps and
cuts off blaze's left arm preventing him
from using the ring of judgment while
they think they're already safe a lady
who turns out to be also from the gang
takes an old woman hostage suddenly
another blazer girihana arrives and
subdues them later iki thanks him for
saving them kilihana ironically refers
that weak people need to be saved and
tells that iki had a match against him
but ran away he also announces that
he'll be iki's first opponent in the
upcoming match
during the selection match stella
shizuku and alice easily defeat their
opponents meanwhile iki begins studying
kirihana's noble art which renders him
invisible and makes it difficult to even
detect him using the other senses later
ikki meets up with shizuku's roommate
and tells him about his previous match
against girihara during the previous
school year when his family still had
influence over the academy superiors
girihana had been harassing him with his
device and iki refused to fight back
believing it would be used as an excuse
to expel him in the next day's match
girihana starts off by activating his
noble art which covers the battlefield
in an illusionary forest at first ikki's
able to reduce his location by observing
the visible arrows he fires but kirihana
uses a new improved technique he
developed which also allows his arrows
to become invisible and injures iki
enraged stella stands up for iki and
tells him to continue fighting
using everything he learned about
gidehana's attacks a rejuvenated iki
pinpoints his location with his noble
art and defeats him then collapses from
exhaustion when ikki wakes up at the
hospital he sees stella and confesses
his feelings for her initially
embarrassed by the confession she then
kisses his cheek the two then promised
to meet and fight each other in the
final match of the festival
two weeks have passed since iki's battle
with girihana iki has progressed through
the following matches with ease quickly
losing his school nickname of the worst
one and gaining the new nickname of
another one and becoming popular with
the other students volunteering to
mentor them in perfecting their strength
using what he's learnt about
swordsmanship however stella becomes
frustrated when iki isn't paying enough
attention to her during the time since
they became a couple iki later takes
everyone to the local swimming pool for
more training there shizuku and alice
discuss about the former's affections
towards iki despite their biological
relation meanwhile after talking about
her and iki's relationship to a
classmate stella and iki get into a
fight after she reveals her
misinterpretation that iki no longer
likes her which he quickly denies after
the two call down and settle out their
problems iki suggests they both blurt
out what they want to do right now with
each other and stellar agrees then they
look at each other and kiss on the way
back iki and stella are informed that
their next opponents are members from
the student council as iki and stella
continue to make progress in the
selection matches iki notices he's being
stalked by a female student who
eventually identifies herself as ayase
the daughter of a famous swordsman she'd
been hoping to ask iki to help her
improve her swordsmanship but was unable
to approach him directly because of her
fear of men he agrees to help her to the
surprise of both stella and shizuku
during training he deduces the isa's
problem lies in an imitation of a
father's style which is impossible to
accomplish he then proposes that since
she's now fully dedicated to imitating
her father's style and can't utilize any
other technique she must adjust her
position by understanding her anatomy
with this advice in mind ayase is able
to land a hit on iki with ease while
accompanying rmc and isa home stella
asks shizuku if she is jealous of isa
and she replies that she isn't then
hopes that stella will always take care
of iki and never betray him one night
while having dinner with ayase iki and
stellameter blazer known as sword eater
he begins harassing isa and then injures
an unresisting iki when he stands up for
her afterwards the trio is approached by
members of academy student council who
commend iki for not retaliating against
the sword eater as they walk back home
iki and ayase are informed that in the
next matchup they're going to be
fighting each other the following night
iki meets up with isa on the school
rooftop at her request and makes a
situation prompting iki to use his noble
art to save her she reveals that she
planned to prevent iki from using his
abilities during the match since he can
only use it once every 24 hours now we
can exhausted iki somehow makes it back
to his room where stella who was having
a perverted dream awakens and helps him
now he has to fight isa without his
abilities and on a battlefield rigged
with traps that she said however iki who
has learned why she's so determined
still wants to help her regain her pride
despite sustaining serious damage iki
isn't only able to see her through and
defeat isa but also to break through to
her and offer his help so that she could
regain what she's lost accompanied by
stella and ayase iki goes to isa's
family dojo and challenges sword eater
to a jewel to reclaim the dojo as the
fight progresses iggy takes some damage
from his opponent's device reminding isa
of her father's fight with the sword
eater which hurts her internally when
ayase wants to stop the fight stella
stops her telling her that she won't be
able to get the dojo back if she does
and that iki is actually having fun and
enjoying the fight just like her father
did she then realizes that the apology
her father gave at the end of the fight
was to saw dieter for not being able to
execute his final move and collapsing
midway in the match using isa's father
secret technique himself iki wins the
match and restores the dojo later ayase
confesses her foul play to the school
also her father regains consciousness in
hospital the director sends iki and
stella to a training camp stella is
initially excited believing she now gets
to spend some time alone with iki but it
turns out they were sent to help the
student council with cleaning up the
training field after cleaning stella
insists in climbing up the mountains to
view the waterfall with iki despite
having a fever caught in a sudden storm
they take refuge in an abandoned lodge
and stellar so clothes lead to an
embarrassing situation later they're
attacked by a puppet user blazer who
controls golems but the attack is
stopped by the student council members
while student council president herself
deals with the blazer meanwhile shizuku
returns to a family mansion to face her
father and learns that her next opponent
will be the student council president
iki and stella are worried because
they've seen student council power for
themselves shizuku is determined to win
to prove that she's strong enough to
stand beside her brother against
everyone but the president is calm and
collected as the battle progresses
shizuku realizes that the president is
faster and stronger than her so she opts
for a defensive weapon and long-range
water ice tactics she covers the arena
in ice to give herself a terrain
advantage but the president is able to
see through her attacks when she
demonstrates the ability to instantly
close the gap with her trackless step
shizuku fills the arena with a thick
mist to use her final attack against her
but unfortunately loses the match to the
president's attack
the ethics committee which is controlled
by iki's family and an ugly bastard
create a scandal by photographing stella
and iki kissing on school grounds ike
later gets arrested and is placed in a
special prison owned by his family where
he's continuously interrogated and
forced to fight the selection matches
even while being imprisoned despite the
odds being against him iki continues to
win his matches during one of his
hearings he appeals to speak to his
father which to everyone's amazement is
granted however his father tells him to
quit the selection process if iki wins
he would cause unrest in his father's
organization by inspiring those without
magical ability to aim higher ikki's
distraught that his father still refuses
to acknowledge him the ethics committee
informs ike that his final opponent in
the selection matches will be the
student council president and if he
loses he'll have to give up his dream
iki's final match with the president is
to be televised to the whole world
stella and alice win their final matches
and spots at the seven stars battle
festival even though exhausted and
wounded from his prior matches and ill
treatment in prison and haunted by
self-doubt iki arrives at the arena in
time cheered on by everyone at his
academy the president as well as
everybody else know that the fight is
fixed but still want to test ike's
resolve to fight he defeats the
president with one hit and surprises
everyone refusing to accept the outcome
of the match the ugly bastard tries to
attack iki but stella runs to his rescue
and easily knocks off the bastard along
the way estella is near iki he proposes
to her while it was still being
broadcast to the entire world a ceremony
is held honoring the school's six
representatives for the seven star
swords arts festival and ike's name the
leader and flag bearer by the student
council president
so this is it for today's video if you
liked the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time